bon alors aujourd'hui on va jouer à
faire des crêpes géante et quand je dis
j'ai honte c'est pas une crêpe plate est
petit c'est une crêpe comme ça et passe
vraiment comme ça alors pour la pâte à
crêpes il faut du lait de la farine bien
sûr du beurre des oeufs et du maïs que
nous avons acheté en boîte et simplement
mis dans un bol et pour la farce il faut
deux choses il faut d'une part des
épinards tous les enfants et les
épinards de pippo paye bien sûr il faut
du jambon blanc et sérieux voyez c'est
pas des gens bons pour anémiée ça et du
gruyère 400 g de gruyère est un tout
petit peu d'huile trois ou quatre
cuillères à soupe d'huile et avec ça
vous allez voir miley christophe georges
bouko et avec ça on va faire des
miracles d'accord
on va faire une pâte à crêpes vin tous
les tubes christophe bon alors pour
faire une pâte à crêpes qui va prendre
la tombe vers et il va verser
2,3 tasse de lait à l'e3 tasse de lait
et une vers celle d'anton bol
allez je vais t'aider
et 3
et là dedans tu veux ajouter une tasse
et demi de farine voilà
une tasse et voilà une demi tasse et
avec le fouet qu'est ce qu'il va faire
avec le fouet tu vas
tu vois pendant ce temps je vais prendre
du beurre ici et une demie plaques de
beurre je vais la mettre
à fondre
voilà
alors remuer tu vois un mélange bien des
bords sinon ça ferait les grumeaux qui
sont pas très bons non des crêpes alors
ça y est alors tu vas valérie tu veux
casser 5e dans le box c'est casser les
oeufs oui alors qu'à 5 dans la baule à
christophe dans le bol un pas à côté du
bol
et voilà allez vas-y fais le mieux pour
elle
es5 et christophe coin mais toujours
comme un grand
à la regardes tu vois tu vas commencer
par appuyer et comme ça tu vas casse
était jaune quand tu y as cassé des
jeunes après c'est facile qui n'a plus
qu'à louer pour mélanger
alors valérie qu'il va rajouter
dans cette attaque rete 4 cuillères à
soupe d'huile du 2
mai toi directement dessus tu sais comme
ça tu vas faire semblant de mettre 4
cuillères mais en fait il sera que ça
les fait
ça c'est le secret de la pâte à crêpes
mettre un tout petit peu d'huile dedans
cela rend souple léger intérieur c'est
très très bien
alors qui c'est qui veut ça les qui
c'est qui ces salles et
en général en salle une pincée parent
seulement comme tu as un que tu rajoutes
et autant de matières t va rajouter 10
pincée de sel c'est à dire deux fois
mais des grosses basses et regarde toi
tu mets des pincées de de deux jeunes
filles de familles du c 4 6 7 8 9 à toi
la dernière c'est
revenu
tu vois le beurre est fondue
ont valeur ajoutée dans la casserole
et valérie tu rajoutes le maïs et ont
fait la première cape en sont d'accord
tout le maïs dedans
mais j'ai agi avec les doigts n'ai pas
peur
on est très pour la première crêpe
alors tu vois on est juste un tout petit
peu de beurre dans la poêle
il va fond christophe tu me fasses la la
pâte à crêpes qu'on fasse la première
crèche géante
voilà regarde on va mettre de cuillère
de pâte à crêpes mais en allant bien
chercher les maïs tu vois
et pendant que cette première crêpe va
cuire on va faire la béchamel
alors pour faire la béchamel
tu veux venir ici mon chéri tu veux
faire la béchamel tu vas mettre tu vois
le cardinaux plaques de beurre
là
avec une belle mais belle cuillère en
bois qui va remuer pour que ça fonde
et quand ce sera fondue tueur ajoutera 2
cuillères à soupe de farine
de faire tourner la clé christophe
diss et
j'essaye d'avoir la première téphra les
autres il en faut six comme satisfaits
alors qu'ils tentent d'exercer
regarde
je suis sûr que tu l'aurais fait mieux
que moi
voilà alors la tombe et répondu alors tu
veux ajouter 2 cuillères à soupe de
farine bien pointu c'est pas la peine
d'un canton plainte est le fait du la
voilà une
eau le trop pointu cela vraiment notre
pointu là comme sade du revenu mais
t'accueillir en bois tu vois pour faire
cuire
et l'asie c'est bien
alors il faut que ça devienne un peu
brin pas très brun tu vois mais un tout
petit peuple pageau
ami rené
à toi moi je veux pas regarder un petit
va allez vas-y 20 mai pas faire quoi
qu'est-ce que tu ris quand on fera
d'autres allaient
formidable
bâti vote il va parce qu'elle va ici dit
on
allait continuer à venir ce sera là ce
sera la crêpe demi géante voilà c'est
tout les autres on les fera géant
géantes c'est là un champion à les
loisirs mais là tu vois ça commence à
devenir un peu brin alors tu va rajouter
deux tasses de laitue voitures tourner
ton verre n'oubliez pas que le vert oula
tu as fais toujours 20 centilitres un
très important pour les mesures
plein plein plein il fallait qu'elle
soit plein de traces bout série
voilà alors que tu rajoute encore un
petit peu
formidable voilà
le club et maintenant tu remues
rajoutant un petit peu de sel
où est passé le ce qui en prime celle
christophe
de 3 pincées
c'était crêpe est prête
on va en faire une autre
remue revue tu vas voir cela de venir et
p christophe tu veux faire la crêpe
entièrement
alors mettez de
thé de louche
avec beaucoup de malice tu vois voilà
c'est ça
une louche
on va chercher le maïs ou fonds
et de louche
très bien
regarde bien regarde bien ce qui se
passe là d'un seul coup ça va devenir ep
personne n'a jamais su pourquoi la
béchamel est presque terminée on met les
épinards à chauffer tu vois les a mis là
dedans avec un peu de beurre du sel bien
sûr du poivre si tu aimes ça dit non
mais c'est qu'elle est très belle tu
avais jamais un broyeur christophe
alors tu sais ce qu'on va faire nous
pendant qu'elle continue de tourner ça
béchamel on va couper les tranches de
jambon
avec un couteau
en deux
comme ça
et puis une fois qu'on a coupé en deux
on va lui couper en lamelles
et sa
valeur ajoutée dans
la baie j'aimerais el hadj épinards
quoique ces très bonnes gens devant
epinal mais tu vois aujourd'hui on a
fait du jambon des épinards des crêpes
avec du maïs
alors tu mélanges tout ça mon chéri
je crois qu'on va se régaler
voilà
ces mélanges et on va terminer en
mettant du gruyère râpé il y en a 400
grammes on va presque tous m un presque
tous pas tout tu vas voir pourquoi tout
à l'heure
voilà et pendant que tu remues
nom christophe on va préparer la
première
la première comme
la première crêpe est encore chaude de
l'année au sein du plat
on prend les épinards
voilà tutelle avec le couteau tu veux
pour canadiens partout
un passé je crois la note encore une
bonne cuillère
comme ça les épinards un peu les
épinards ah ça c'est pas croyable bien
pour la première fois de ta vie tu vas
les aimer c'est pas pourquoi tu mets une
crème dessus tu veux sans la casser il a
trop vite et de mettre parce qu'il est
un peu fragile
et là on va mettre
une couche
ça ça a l'air bon je crois que c'est
un site il étale
on remet encore une crêpe
encore des épinards
personne ne voit comment on peut mettre
les voix personnes nous regardent on est
tous les trois tout seul dans la cuisine
on peut faire tout ce qu'on veut
bon alors maintenant c'est un mini
crêpes quand va mettre dessus tout c'est
celle que tu as retourner si bien voilà
et tu vas mettre le fromage avec tam un
témoin qui va le répartir dessus sur
tout le sud
asie
et voilà et ça on va le mettre au four
thermostat 6 pour le gars c'est bien sûr
250 pour l'électricité
pendant
pendant combien de temps
20 minutes qui voit même pas alors après
terreur c'est merveilleux tu vas voir
c'est fantastique ce qui va sortir de là
bon on va voir ce qu'a donné notre
crèche géante
regardez-moi ça
on la coupe
c'était un vrai repas pour 6 personnes
rsa
eh bien bon appétit
évite les épinards triste et enfin moi
je te
hais moi alors
je prends le reste
[Musique]